It's time to expose the secure
monolith pod externally and
to do that will create
a kubernetes service.
Explore the monolith
service configuration file.
Things to note, one we've got a selector
which is used to automatically find and
expose any pause with the labels.
App equals monolith,
secure equals enabled.
Two, now have to expose the no port
here because this is how we will for
external traffic from port 31 thousand
to engine next on port four four three.
Use the kubect1 create command
to create the monolith service
from them on the service
configuration part.
This output is telling us you're
using a port to expose the service.
You're going to have port collisions if
another app tries to bind to that port
on one of your servers.
Kubernetes handles this port
assignment for us normally.
Here, I chose one so that it's easier
to configure health checks later on.
Use the G Cloud compute
firewall rules command
to allow traffic to the mildest
service on the exposed no port.
Now that everything is set up.
We should be able to hit the secure
monolith servers from outside cluster,
and what value is in port 40.
First let's get an IP address for
one of our nodes.
And then try hitting the secure
Monolith service using Curl.
That's not working.
What's going wrong?
On that note I'm going to stop here and
see if Carter can help us troubleshoot.